I feel really sick I'm hearing the boys
bring me back my creature
you should be extremely afraid
we are fit
I'm Eddie Brock I'm the reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
look around in the world who do you see
a planet on the brink of collapse human
beings are disposable like man and
symbiote a mind this is a new race your
species the higher life-form
[Applause]
all right
we cannot just hurt people
aha
a deal i clear so many circle time
to that power it's not completely off
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now
today cooperate
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
oops
we'll always come at a cost
everybody is Charlie we got a bunch of
new venom to break down and some really
cool Thor Easter eggs
so now venom is connected to Thor in a
really cool mythological way because
they're doing some really crazy cosmic
stuff with the venom title right now so
I'll explain what's going on with that
there's new giveaway stuff I'll talk
about at the end of the video be sure to
subscribe to get everything because it's
only gonna get crazier so you see a
whole bunch more of Carlton Drake versus
Eddie Brock after Eddie gets the
symbiote you see a couple scenes where
he tries to call his girlfriend Michelle
Williams character I don't feel so good
then it starts to manifest and you see
Carlton Drake on the phone with him
bring me back my creature so he's stolen
one of the symbiotes obviously we know
that riot is going to be one of the
other symbiotes from the comics they
haven't been very clear if they're doing
all five of the symbiotes from the
lethal protector storyline or if they'll
just be Easter eggs for all five and
it's really just the venom in the riots
symbiotes maybe a third one if you wanna
count carnage but he's probably more of
a post-credits tag so technically I
don't count him amongst these symbiotes
and they haven't confirmed whether or
not he's going to be the offspring of
venom like the comics or if it's gonna
be some different origin like could be a
completely separate entity I know a lot
of you do want toxin at some point I'm
sure if they do carnage in the second
film like it sounds like they're teasing
then they can totally get to toxin if
they want to in a third film but it all
just depends on how this first venom
film does if it does well then of course
anything is possible there's a much
longer scene with Donna Diego when she
gets the symbiote the riot symbiote so
even though she is scream in the comics
I believe that in this scene here she's
bonded to the riot symbiote then it
leaves her and joins Carlton Drake
that's when they become like full-blown
comic book riot that's why he looks so
huge here so his venom versus riot in
Eddie Brock versus Carlton Drake both
bonded to their symbiotes but the really
cool thing that I don't know if they're
gonna get to in this movie probably not
maybe a future film is the idea of the
other powers the symbiote has there's a
brand new one they just stay buted in
the comics the symbiote can now manifest
a wings because of some new abilities
that it got when it was joined to the
god of the symbiotes whose name is null
so the really cool authority story
connecting him to venom now is the tale
of Grendel which obviously this epic
Saxon poem of course if you're gonna do
that in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Thor's characters the most appropriate
one now what they're saying is that
inside the Marvel Universe the Grendel
from the epic poem is actually the
primordial symbiote the very first
symbiote created by the celestial god of
the void remember during Thor the dark
world were Odin's explaining the history
of the universe and he talks about the
blackness of space and the void before
creation in the Big Bang how after the
Big Bang the Celestials and the other
races rose up and cast them down in how
they sought to take that back by using
the reality stone so in this new story
where we learn about Noah he's
effectively the god of that time before
creation so he's still crazy powerful
after the Big Bang
so when eternity creates the Celestials
and they start populating the universe
with lesser races like the Eternals and
everywhere else the god of the void
creates a symbiote from his shadow that
he turns into the necro sword that was
later wielded by gore the god butcher
during the big thaw repec when he went
around killing all the gods
so one during this new story Noah gets
really pissed off talking about gore
about how he didn't understand the full
powers of the necro sword it's actually
called the all-black it's the primordial
symbiote that then eventually bonds with
someone else on planet earth and becomes
the Grendel of the Grendel poem that
Thor then strikes down so is this big
crossover with Thor story through Gore
the god butcher the necro sword in the
Grendel tale the new mythology behind
the Clint are now is is that this god of
the void no uses the symbiotes as
aspects of itself through their hosts he
can actually learn things about what's
happening across the universe he can
reabsorb symbiotes and what happens is
is that the more symbiotes that combine
with each other the more powerful they
can be the more abilities they unlock so
for a brief period Venom symbiote is
reabsorbed back into this primordial
Grendel horde it's able to escape before
Noah can cut the bond with Eddie so that
it returns to Eddie when he rebind with
Eddie they find that the symbiote was
able to retain some of those extra
powers that it gained when it was
connected to Noel's horde so the whole
thing now is that the symbiote is
learning about abilities that it never
knew
and it's also remembering that there's
strength in numbers so I know it sounds
a little crazy and they're not gonna
really get into this stuff in the movie
but it's cool mythology about how the
symbiotes work where they come from why
they were created in the first place and
is a cool way of connecting them to
other big Marvel franchises like what's
happening with Thor remember Thor
Ragnarok effectively turned hella into
their version of Gore the god butcher
especially in the way that her powers
work like just manifesting weapons but
it's also really cool with this story to
learn why the necro sword had the
abilities that it did at the time it was
a really cool story but now it's just
broadening it a little bit and deepening
the mythology what are the really easy
things I think for them to pull off
though is the idea that symbiotes can
absorb other symbiotes or at least
combine with them so that you do have
multiple personalities within one person
like Eddie Brock wielding multiple
symbiotes when they do that they gain
all these crazy stacking bonuses to
their powers but the funny thing is is
in this recent story where they're doing
this Venna makes the joke that even
though he's absorbed a piece of this
primordial Grendel symbiote and they're
crazy powerful now he's still not as
powerful as Thor let me know in the
comments though what other comic book
venom abilities do you want to see the
movies do there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway like I
said all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a mark over lated
comments on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last big video [ __ ]
please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
what's happening with Thor 4 in
guardians of the galaxy 3 and click here
for brand-new Game of Thrones thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]